the following is a report from an
experiment in which 682 is exposed to
999 in hopes that it would curb the
creatures on this side already
scp-682 repeats the word happy for
several minutes
laughing occasionally before escalating
into nonstop laughter as a laughter
continues 6/8 two rolls on its back
slamming its tail upon the floor with
dangerous force scp-682 and i99 continue
the tickle fight until 682 finally wears
down and appears to fall asleep with
what would appear to be a smile on its
face 50 minutes after with an activity
to d-class personnel into the room to
retrieve 99999 moved 6-8 to immediately
wakes up on unleashes an unidentifiable
wave of energy from its body
all the while laughing manically all
persons within the waves range collapse
into crippling fits of left or allowing
associated to escape and slaughter all
in its path meanwhile and then I quickly
rescues as many persons as it can taking
into a safe place to recover him 682 s
laughter wave while agents suppress and
REE contain 682 despite the tragedy that
682 it brought upon the facility and
that man is not showing any fear towards
the creature and in fact has made
gestures suggesting that it wants to
play with 682 again 6:18 well that has
stated
oh boy
Oh
you